The Christmas pudding is in decline.
In a recent survey,
less than half the population
said they included one
on their yuletide table.
And that figure hides
a significant age bias.
The younger you are,
the less you fancy a bit of pudding.
How has this dish,
once emblematic of Britishness,
come to such a sorry state?
What we call Christmas pudding has
its roots in the medieval period,
when a rich concoction
called plum pottage
became associated
with winter feasting.
Pottage was just a name
for a soupy stew,
and this one contained
beef, spice and dried fruit.
When a pudding version appeared,
sometime around
the end of the Tudor era,
the two co-existed happily
for many decades.
Plum pudding was similar in style,
but with no actual meat,
just lots of beef suet,
and was thickened with breadcrumbs
and flour with added eggs,
until the mixture was thick enough
to be put in a wetted,
floured cloth and boiled.
The resulting speckled brown,
cannonball-shaped pudding
wasn’t sophisticated
but was delicious.
It tumbled rapidly into recipe books
with as many variants
as there were writers.
It was part of the main meal,
sometimes eaten before the meats
but more often with them.
And it quickly became seen as the
ideal accompaniment to roast beef,
a bit like modern chutney.
Beef and plum pudding became the
English dishes of the 18th Century.
The plum pudding was eaten
widely across the winter,
though it was hardly
a dish for the poor
with all its spice
and expensive imported fruit.
It could be made in advance
though it was more often
prepared when needed,
and it would keep for months
making it ideal as a gift.
However, as the 19th Century wore on
it became increasingly
associated with feasting,
in particular at Christmas
because it was eaten with beef
and beef was so ubiquitous
on the Christmas table,
the plum pudding
itself came to be seen
as a particularly Christmassy food.
And was even served
when no beef was in the offing.
In 1845, Eliza Acton
became the first person
to publish a recipe for it
called Christmas pudding.
And it slowly slunk
to later in the meal.
It also got gradually sweeter
and squishier.
For it was now often moulded
in an ornate copper mould
for the tables of the rich,
or a simple bowl
for those of lesser means.
Habits change and the 20th Century
left the plum pudding behind,
though as Christmas pudding
it survived.
No longer eaten as part of the main
meal, it was now a sweet.
And served increasingly
with accompaniments deemed fitting
for its new definition -
cream or custard or brandy butter.
The tradition of setting it on fire
was a Victorian one,
but in the 1920s
it garnered more mythology
such as the taking, rather seriously,
of the old Victorian joke
that the pudding
should be made on stir up Sunday -
the fifth Sunday before Christmas.
A sixpence was sometimes
added to the mixture as well,
a pale shadow of
another festive tradition,
this time related to the ancestor
of the Christmas cake -
Twelfth cake -
which had had tokens concealed in it
to be found amongst much revelry.
Today our Christmas dinner
has swollen to such proportions
that a hefty pudding
with a rich sauce
can sometimes seem
too much to handle.
Perhaps this year
we should go back to basics -
beef with gravy and a slice
of plum pudding, anyone?